un desdoblamiento complejo ocurre cuando
un protón tiene dos tipos diferentes de
vecinos y un buen ejemplo de esto es el
protón en azul que circule en el
zinemaldia el protón en azul tiene una
señal con un desplazamiento químico de
alrededor de 6.7 partes por millón aquí
abajo está una ampliación de la señal
para el protón azul veamos a los
protones vecinos el protón azul está en
este carbono y tenemos un carbono vecino
justo aquí con un protón por lo que hay
un protón vecino hay otro carbono vecino
con un protón por lo que tenemos dos
protones vecinos intentemos aplicar la
regla de n más uno aquí
gm es igual a dos tenemos dos protones
vecinos y esperaríamos n más un picos
así que dos más uno es igual a tres por
lo que es una señal con tres picos o un
green
lee
sí
pero eso no es lo que vemos para la
señal para el protón en azul vemos
dos tres cuatro líneas aquí por lo que
la regla de n 1 no funciona en este caso
y eso es porque la regla de n 1 funciona
cuando los protones vecinos son
equivalentes y aquí los dos protones
vecinos no son equivalentes así que
necesitamos una nueva manera de explicar
la señal para el protón en azul y
usaremos lo que es llamado un árbol de
desdoblamiento empezaremos con la señal
para el protón azul aquí está la señal
para el protón azul será dividida por el
protón al lado de ella
este protón en rojo y la constante de
acoplamiento entre el protón en azul y
en rojo es de 12 g
continuamos y mostremos que esta señal
se divide en un 'doblete'
déjame continuar dibujando las líneas
azules aquí obtenemos a la señal
dividida en un doblete la constante de
acoplamiento es de 12 hertz esta
distancia de aquí representa 12 hertz
porque podemos pensar la dividiéndose en
un doblete podrías pensar en una
variación de la regla de n más uno aquí
estamos hablando de un protón vecino
es igual a 1
uno más uno es igual a dos dividimos la
señal en un doblete con dos líneas
ahora pensemos en lo que pasa con el
otro protón con este este tomará cada
línea del 'doblete' que acabamos de
hacer y la dividirá en otro 'doblete'
así que esta línea se desdobla en un
doblete y esta línea se desdobla en un
doblete la constante de acoplamiento
esta vez es de 6 hertz esta distancia de
aquí representa 6 hertz y esta distancia
representa 6 hertz así que porque se
dividió esta línea en 2 una vez más
podemos usar una modificación de la
regla de n 1 estamos hablando de un
vecino aquí n es igual
más uno es igual a 2
cada línea se divide en dos cada línea
se divide en un doblete esta línea y
esta línea esta línea se divide en un
doblete también obtenemos obtenemos
cuatro líneas para esta señal del protón
azul por aquí vemos esas cuatro líneas 1
2 3 y 4 y llamamos a este un doble-doble
t qué pasaría si las constantes de
acoplamiento fueran las mismas
pretendamos que ambas son 12 hertz
continuamos dibujando lo que veríamos
para esta señal tenemos nuestra señal
para el protón azul se desdobla en un
doblete por el protón rojo así que
continuamos dibujando nuestro doblete
aquí y digamos que esta distancia
representa dos ejes
y digamos que la constante de
acoplamiento por aquí es de 12 hertz
también en lugar de 6 hertz cada línea
del doble que acabamos de dibujar se
divide en otro 'doblete' por nuestro
otro vecino y esta vez mostraré una
constante de acoplamiento de 12 hertz
cada línea del doblete en azul se divide
en otro doblete la línea azul en la
izquierda se divide en un doblete y la
línea en azul en la derecha se divide en
un doblete debido a nuestro único protón
vecino y he cambiado la constante de
acoplamiento así que ahora supongamos
que tenemos 12 aquí por lo que las
constantes de acoplamiento son las
mismas y nota lo que esto nos da nos da
un triplete aquí hay una línea y luego
obtenemos este pico y luego obtenemos
este pico si las constantes de
acoplamiento son las mismas obtienes un
triplete
obtienes lo que la regla de n 1 predijo
así que lo que nos falta pensar es el
origen de la regla n 1 hagamos otro
ejemplo vamos aquí abajo y veamos esta
molécula nos enfocaremos en este protón
aquí en azul bien y tenemos protones
vecinos cierto este protón vecino la
constante de acoplamiento entre esos dos
es de 12 hertz y luego por aquí tenemos
dos protones vecinos y la constante de
acoplamiento entre los protones magenta
y el azul es de 7 hertz pensemos en la
señal para el protón en azul aquí
tenemos la señal para el protón en azul
la cual no está dividida pensemos en lo
que el protón rojo hará tenemos un
vecino
11 es igual a 2 vamos a dividir la señal
para el protón en azul en dos por lo que
obtenemos un 'doblete' aquí así que
déjame dibujar el 'doblete' la constante
de acoplamiento era de 12 hertz esta
distancia de aquí es de 12 hertz muy
bien ahora tenemos ahora tenemos una
situación donde estamos pensando en los
protones magenta y tenemos dos de ellos
n es igual a 22 más uno es igual a 3 los
protones magenta desdoblarán cada línea
del 'doblete' que acabamos de hacer en
un triplete obtendremos un triplete aquí
déjame continuar dibujando lo tenemos un
triplete y nuestra constante de
acoplamiento es de 7 hertz así que
déjame ver si puedo dibujar eso
esta distancia supuestamente representa
hertz así que déjame dibujar eso esta
distancia es de 7 hearts
esta distancia corresponde a 7
hertz
y una línea de nuestro doblete se divide
en un triplete ahora
lo mismo pasa con la otra línea cierto
lo mismo pasa con esta línea de aquí
tenemos que dividir eso en un triplete
debido a estos protones magenta
dividiremos eso en un triplete una vez
más tenemos que pensar en una distancia
de 7 aquí de 7
hertz en ambos lados tenemos 7 hertz
déjame continuar dibujando eso esto está
hablando de 7
esto
de siete hits
esa línea se divide en un triplete
dibujemos eso aquí 1 2 y 3
finalmente cuatros picos se esperan en
la señal para este producto en azul
2 3 4 5 y 6
esperamos 6 5
para la señal de este protón azul debido
a los protones vecinos que están en
diferentes tipos de ambientes así que
este es un desdoblamiento complejo